y yo les voy a platicar un poquito mi
historia de por qué me volví emprendedor
pero luego al final lo que les quiere
decir es porque creo que deberíamos de
emprender todos en mexico
para empezar ven a ponerles esto
yo de niño era un desastre
siempre tuve problemas con la autoridad
me corrieron de casi todas las escuelas
que estuve en primaria en secundaria
me chocaba hacerle caso a los adultos
nada más porque me decían lo que me
decían o sea siempre como que quería
investigar porque las cosas porque los
maestros decían que algo era así
y éste me costó mucho trabajo la escuela
como a los 13 años
mi papá compró una computadora está en
la computadora se exceden increíble /
vieja pero les juro que funcionaba la
verdad es que me enamoré de la
computación no podía creer que podías
programar el que podías jugar y que
podía usar en la pasada de verdad tres o
cuatro horas al día metido en la
computadora tratando y ahí las autoras
eran otra cosa más para que tengan una
idea el disco duro de esta computadora
de la 3.5 megabytes imagínense cuánto le
cabía
y luego cuando llegue a la universidad
ya me había tranquilizado ya estudiaba y
le hacía caso a las autoridades me metí
al tec de monterrey
y en el tec había una carrera que era
licenciado en sistemas computacionales
administrativos y está padrísimo aprendo
por un lado a operar un negocio y por
otro lado aprendo y sigo aprendiendo
computación y sigo haciendo lo que me
gusta
después de un rato está en el me cuenta
que para que estoy aprendiendo
computación fíjense qué extraño no o sea
no me voy a dedicar a ser programador no
voy a hacer esto y me ofrecieron una
beca en la universidad de pensilvania
y dije ya sé lo que quiero hacer quiero
hacer cine 2 me fui a la universidad
pensilvania y me puse a estudiar cine
y comunicación en cine y mi idea era
regresar a mexico y volverme un director
de cine sobre lo que yo quería hacer
cuando me graduó de la universidad
regreso a mexico las películas eran un
desastre en esa época eran lola la
trailera 14 la risa en vacaciones 18 las
ficheras era la peor época del cine en
méxico no habían apoyos para hacer cine
esto estuvo dificilísimo dedicarme al
cine me puse a hacer publicidad
trabajé un ratito en casas productoras
hice un par de documentales mucho
anuncios
pero no me encantó y un día un cuate mío
me enseñó internet y me dijo oye tienes
que ver esto yo había escuchado de
internet pero realmente no sabía lo que
era nunca lo había visto
de nuevo sé que suena hace siglos
ustedes ya está en la escuela con
internet o nosotros tenemos y
computadora en la escuela
y vientos dije híjole esto está
espectacular fui a su casa me enseña
internet y me enseña que el intercambio
de acciones y jugaba a gamón por
internet este es el bagaje que él jugaba
y era divertidísimo porque voy a jugar
bayamón con toda la gente del mundo
podrías intercambiar cosas podrías
chatear con cualquier persona en
cualquier lugar del mundo o sea no podía
creer
me volvió loco el internet les juro que
me sentía yo así dije
esto es la nueva imprenta de gutenberg
esto va a cambiar al ser humano dije a
mí que me gustan los medios y me gusta
la comunicación me voy a dedicar ahora a
internet mucho mejor
y entonces cambié me salió lo que estaba
haciendo
casualmente el hermano menor de este
amigo estaba atrás de él haciendo su
página de internet yo le pregunté oye
cómo que tu página de internet y me
explicó y me dijo mira yo el lenguaje
dice mhtml puedes hacer tus propias
páginas
yo traía la experiencia que me gustan
las computadoras de que estudia algo de
programación el técnico y le dijo ya ver
enseñando el señor html y me encantó
las siguientes tres semanas me encerré
haciendo mi propia página de internet
y acabé haciendo mi página personal de
internet este era mi página personal de
internet
se los juro que era súper moderna
de hecho chistosísimo porque le puse un
contador como el que ven
y cada vez que yo entraba el contador
avanzaba muchísimo se dije no pues sé
cuánta gente está viendo mi página de
internet
claro la mitad o tres cuartas partes del
contador se moviera yo mismo entrando a
leer la página de internet
pero habían un montón de otras gentes
entrando que yo no sabía de dónde era ni
nada pero entraba gente a ver mi página
me dejaban recados y mandaban emails
ahora la dirección de mi página era una
dirección extrañísima era el world estar
a las direcciones para entrar a
world.com bioserve puntocom
diagonal para los de unai yus els
diagonal 11 7 osea peña más el número de
frente a la página
y sin embargo la gente le encontraba
entrada
entonces alguien me dijo oye deberías
ponerlo en dominio si ya tienes
visitantes imagínate si haces la
dirección mucho más sencilla
2 me puse a pensar acuérdese que en ese
entonces el internet era con módem
si no sabe lo que es un módem pero no
para tito que tu marca vas zonabancos
y en trabas a internet horrible además
porque si descolgado tomé el teléfono
se acaba de la conexión
pero las páginas bajaban lentísimas
bajado en línea por línea no era como
vita
y entonces dije a ver en internet todo
es lento y no hay una representación
mexicana en internet
yo quiero que mi página sea algo
mexicano y represente algo rápido
me puse a pensar bueno qué hago qué hago
entonces me metí a ver los dominios y
registre spill y gonzález puntocom
dije buenísimo nadie lo tenía y está
perfecto
empiezo a subir la página esponsales
puntocom y de repente y esto para estos
autores estos son jóvenes donde es
ningún tipo de negocio en edad y de
repente me hablan de warner brothers y
me dicen oye
este dominio es nuestro lo queremos de
regreso yo me asusté les dije no no no
si lo registre para ustedes
lo estaba guardando no se preocupe y se
lo regrese
y todos mis cuates me dijeron y
resultaron como nos les cobras los
hubiera costado de mandarte y entonces y
la verdad la vega
así que bueno que otra cosa dije bueno
que dice speedy gonzález 106 3 ándale
puntocom
y dije bueno este número puede mandar
este es un dominio genérico
subo mi pagina estoy a punto de lanzar
la pagina y de repente me llega una
llamada de unos cuates de silicon valley
yo no sabía ni siquiera que era silicon
valley y me dicen oye nos interesa el
dominio de ándale te ofrecemos 10.000
dólares si no lo das yo pensé que era
una broma como diez mil dólares
donde dije bueno dame 20.000 y te lo doy
y me depositaron 20 mil dólares en la
cuenta y dije oiga es el mejor negocio
del universo
yo lo pague para gates 78 dólares para
el dominio el lo venden 20 mil dólares
en dos semanas
y entonces me volví loco empecé a d's
mejor o la mejor del mundo que es
registrar dominios
todo puntocom
hablaban conmigo ustedes y menciona y
vamos a tomar un café y café puntocom
hoy en me encanta el fútbol americano
fútbol americano puntocom donde estamos
en guadalajara guadalajara puntocom
acabé registrando
850 dominios en español
todo punto com porque en esa época
terminal y estaba registrando nada
y entonces empecé a registrar y
registrar y acabé con un dominio que era
méxico puntocom con hot
de hecho dije bueno vamos a ponerle un
eslogan porque el dx estaba tomado le
dije porque no le ponemos que en
internet méxico se escribe con jota
y así empezamos
esta fue la primera iteración de méxico
mundo comer una bandera redonda
padrísimas super moderno luego pasamos a
ésta
porque está más ordenada luego pasamos a
esta porque descubrí que podías hacer
imágenes donde se doblaba la esquinita y
podías disque ver abajo mientras me
encantó
este todo esto lo diseñamos yo solito no
tenemos ni diseñador ni nada
y de repente dije mucha gente entraba se
registraban el dominio nos estábamos
emails en cualquiera de los dominios que
tú podías tener tu email jose alberto a
rodar fútbol americano puntocom
juana roban mexico puntocom con jota
empezó entre un chorro de gente a la
página nos agradecían oye qué bueno que
méxico tiene una presencia mil gracias
pero si había uno que otro que nos decía
malditos gachupines méxico es con x como
lo ponen con j
y entonces yo bueno déjame buscar quién
tiene el dominio con x
encontré un cuarto nueva york se llama
michael smith que tiene el dominio konex
y hablé y le pregunté oye me vendría a
ser dominio méxico punto conmigo si
elige cuanto mi hijo en 15 mil dólares
y dígame si anda lo compraron en 20 mil
méxico por 15 meses está regalado
entonces le compramos el domingo en
medio junto con los subimos todo en
mexico puntocom este real ya la página
oficial en méxico con ya tenemos un
montón de secciones
periodistas turismo recetas de cocina no
tiene idea lo que se volvió
aquí se volvió a una empresa para no ser
es el cuento muy largo en 1999 ah no
perdón mi email que es lo más divertido
era presidente méxico puntocom
y por si fuera poco también tenía
en méjico puntocom yo era méxico
puntocom
en el año
99 nos hablaron de los ángeles un grupo
de gente que estaban interesados en
invertir en méjico puntocom
y les voy a platicar rapidísimo porque
estaba una compañía que se llamaba y
companies yo no sabía que era inversión
de riesgo no tenía idea porque estaba en
esos cuartos interesados en invertir una
empresa que me ganábamos dinero
pero básicamente estaba una competencia
más y compañías que la compañía más
grande de internet en ese momento en los
ángeles estaba
oscar de la hoya de golden boy
productions estaba series ayman que era
el presidente de coca-cola en ese
entonces de marketing de coca cola
estaba el grupo brenner que era un grupo
gigantesco en méxico tenía continental y
mexicana de aviación en los hoteles
camino real estaba un grupo que se llama
parte en el grupo era un grupo de
consultores nos ofrecieron dineral nos
ofrecían 7 millones y pico de dólares
por el 30% de la empresa
es tu tan extraña la plática yo les
pregunté por qué
y entonces mi socio me pateó por abajo
no dijo
y entonces dije por qué tan poquito
aquí estábamos en marzo del 2000
no lo podía ver nos depositaron 7
millones de dólares 7 350 por el 30% de
la empresa
yo me pasé todo el día se los juro
abriendo y cerrando la cuenta banco no
podía escribir y teníamos la cantidad de
dinero
nosotros ganábamos dinero en una empresa
chiquitita rarísima que no sea un día
porque valía tanto
mis acciones valían 7 millones de
dólares y eso que me habían transado
algunas acciones
entonces ella está haciendo planes de
donde gastar y qué casa comprar
para acabar la historia en el 2004
vendió el 90 por ciento de mis acciones
por 25 mil dólares y la mesa de billar
que era lo que teníamos en la oficina
cuando quieran
allí acabó la historia me dijo puntocom
y entonces manejé fue un fracaso
miren no sé yo me acabe saliendo de la
empresa muy enojado porque no me gustó
hacia donde la llevaron
cometí el error de pensar que era un
bebé cuando era una empresa pues yo
sentí que me han quitado el bebé pero al
mismo tiempo aprendí el emprendimiento
aprendí de capital de riesgo aprendí de
cómo hacer sociedades que duren aprendí
muchísimas cosas que me han traído a lo
que soy hoy
después de méxico puntocom
tuve un chorro de empresa estuve sin el
event tuve innova américa y vídeo
tuve la incubadora de innova américa
donde incuba vamos
e ingenieros biomédicos haciendo
productos de medicina
dispositivos médicos del encuadre centro
yo la creé en donde incubamos proyectos
creativos de cine de teatro de diseño
funde guaira méxico que era la
incubadora de tecnología de telefónica y
con toda esta experiencia me salí y
fundé estado méxico instaló mexico´s es
el bebé que traemos ahora
estar en méxico pero me dijo puntocom
por cierto
gonzalo méxico hemos creado más de 900
empresas hemos apoyado a miles de
emprendedores hemos visto como 25 mil
proyectos y yo he invertido a través de
los fondos a través de shark tank y de
manera personal en más de 60 empresas
y lo que les puedo decir es algo súper
importante tenemos un chorro de talento
en mexico
ah y de verdad tenemos un bono
demográfico espectacular donde más de la
mitad de la población es menor a 30 años
donde además es no solo son jóvenes sino
son jóvenes entrenados se ha triplicado
la matrícula universitaria
tenemos de veras un talento que abunda
en el país
la otra cosa que les puedo decir es que
somos el país que más ingenieros
y científicos somos el octavo país del
mundo perdón que crea ingenieros
científicos en el mundo pero esos son
ingeniosos científicos también estamos
creando más mercadólogos más gente de
negocios más gente de diseño o sea de
verdad tenemos toda la materia prima que
queramos somos además un país
increíblemente creativo
esta es una foto real pero les pasen
miles de fotos de cómo somos creativos
vean las porras vean los memes vean los
albures
tenemos realmente todo porque además
geográficamente somos un país súper
beneficiados hay dos países en el mundo
que cruzan continentes turquía que
conecta europa con asia y méxico que
conecta el mundo anglosajón con el mundo
latinoamericano tenemos tratados de
libre comercio con el 70 por ciento del
pib o sea estamos tenemos todo para
emprender
todo el mundo habla de méxico todo el
mundo espera que méxico sea el siguiente
steve jobs el tigre azteca el nuevo
china
andrés oppenheimer dice que todo el
mundo está optimista sobre méxico
excepto los mexicanos
no los quiero dejar con esto
picante esta frase si no hay nada más
poderoso que una idea cuyo tiempo ha
llegado y ha llegado el tiempo de que el
mundo se dé cuenta en países como méjico
deberíamos ser mucho más innovadores y
más competitivos que los demás porque
tenemos más necesidades y porque somos
más creativos pero además tenemos que
exigir que los mexicanos nos enfoquemos
apoyemos el emprendimiento de la
innovación
tenemos todos para salir adelante
michael porter dice que la innovación y
el emprendimiento son la cuestión
central de la prosperidad económica los
países que emprenden y que innovan son
los países ricos los países que no
fomentan el emprendimiento y la
innovación son los países pobres qué
país queremos ser si apoyamos el
emprendimiento hacia un país mucho más
justo mucho más equitativo y mucho más
competitivo
[Aplausos]